so I'm back to tell you why out of all the chicken crab I've ever bought
this has been the most useful and worth all of my money
she's not full right now cause I just got done with some baking oh
questions on my previous video
so I thought I'd address some of them
yes this is on the countertop
this does not go in the refrigerator
this is on top of my stove right now or on the countertop
and it keeps the eggs at room temperature which is perfect for baking with
these eggs are farm fresh eggs
so they have not been processed
so they can sit on the counter for up to two weeks
does the eggs slide down
and as I take eggs off
you can see the eggs slide down and they rotate around
yes I had duck eggs on
even this little egg got stuck
so yes sometimes the eggs do be kinda stuck
and you just kinda like nudge them on their way down and tell them all
it's such a simple divide
and I'm telling you this is the best chicken crap you will ever buy
there is so much useless chickens products on the market
here is now before it's sold out again
add to your cart now to see if you have any outstanding TikTok coupons